رونالدو في طريقه الى الرياض على متن
طائره خاصه وكاظم الساهر يعود الى العراق
من بوابه البصره وحارس الارجنتين يحتاج
الى من يحرسه هذه الاخبار وغيرها بقدمها
لكم من العربيه رياضه
في مرسول بارك الذي يتسع لاكثر من 25,000
شخص يقدم النصر نجمه الجديد كريستيانو
رونالدو مساء الثلاثاء لجماهير الفريق
الملقب بالعالم ويصل رونالدو وعائلته
وتقدمه الاعلامي والفني مساء الاثنين الى
الرياض على متن طائره خاصه ونشر رونالدو
صوره بالفعل له وهو على متن الطائره وقال
نراكم قريبا ومن شلنادي النصر كما نشرت
شريكه جورجينا صوره لها قبل قليل على متن
طائره خاصه كذلك
اختارها اسطوره كره القدم البرازيلي
الراحل بيليه قبل وفاته مقبره خارجه عن
المالوف حيث سيبتني في الطابق التاسع من
مبنى فخم في مقبره عموديه تطل على ملعب
سانتوس النادي الذي شهد على بطولاته وسيتم
الثلاثاء وضع تابلت ذهبي والذي ستكون
جوانب مزخرفه بالعديد من المنقوشات
والمنحوتات في قبول العائله في حضور
الاسره والاصدقاء
بعد احتفاليه الصاخبه كاس العالم اشترى
حارس المنتخب الارجنتيني
بعد الثمن وذلك لحمايته هو واسرته وضرب
الكلب في احد معسكرات القوات البحريه
الامريكيه ويصل وزنه الى 30 كيلوغرام
ويبلغ سعره 20,000 جنيه
اعلن الاتحاد العراقي لكره القدم عن
مشاركه الفنان كاظم الساهر والفنانه رحمه
رياض في حفل افتتاح خليجي 25 وهي المراه
الاولى التي يعود فيها كاظم الساهر الغناء
في العراق منذ وقت طويل جدا مثل التسعينات
وتستضيف مدينه البصره المنافسات من السادس
وحتى التاسعه عشر من يناير الجاي
[موسيقى]